information on itching skin. You can still search things like that itching skin on
this. Quite confident I don't have an article on itching skin. So let's talk about itching skin.
There are certain cancers that do cause, in fact, some people are diagnosed with cancer because
they get super itching. And the reason why that would be is if you have an increase in
bilirubin. So bilirubin is the breakdown of red blood cells and it is excreted through
the bile, through the bile duct. So some cancers can cause an increase in
breakdown of red blood cells and an increase bilirubin that way. Some other cancers can cause a
blockage of the bile duct. So the most common cause of increased bilirubin, which would cause
jaw and business and itchiness of the skin can start with the lower extremities and then upper
extremities. I have talked to people who were diagnosed with lymphoma or leukemia or
bile duct cancer or paekratic cancer because they had this incessive itchiness they were itching so
bad that their legs were bleeding. And that's how they figured out something was wrong with them.
That's what brought them to the doctor went to their regular GP did some tests and the cancer
was discovered. When a personality has a diagnosis of cancer, can there be other reasons for
in itchiness of the skin? Yes, there's lots of other reasons. So we don't want to think that it's
always because of an increased bilirubin. If the person doesn't have any level of gelatist,
their eyes are nice and white, their skin isn't yellowed at all, then it's quite possible and
has nothing to do with what I just said. You can etchiness of the skin because of a decreased fat
consumption because it's really dry outside or in the middle of the winter, very cold weather and you
need to start taking some coconut oil or something like that orally. So there's other possible reasons
for itchiness of the skin dehydration is one possible reason. I'm just going up the top of my head,
but you want to dig always to the reason why. So but when you have cancer, you do want to look at
could there be a blockage in the bile duct? Because many cancers can cause a blockage in the bile duct
even breast cancer or prostate cancer, any cancer, most most kind of area of a taster system for any
cancer is the liver. And if it happens to the taster size right near the kind of bile duct, it could
cause a blockage in the bile duct, and that could increase belly rubin and cause pitching of the
skin. And depending on your total of your skin color, you might not notice the jaundice. So you really
want to look at the whites of the eyes. The whites of the eyes are nice and bright and white that it's
maybe not that. It could be so one of the other possible reasons I talked about, but
if your jaundice at all, if you get yellow eat in the whites of the eyes, you definitely want to
get into your ecologist and get a scale and done of your liver and bile duct.